[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando a gente começa a se relacionar
com a inteligência artificial do mesmo
jeito quem se relaciona com outras
pessoas na sociedade
a gente começa a ver novas implicações e
dá um peso diferente para o momento que
está vivendo
recentemente viu grandes avanços em
inteligência artificial como carros
autônomos reconhecimento de imagem
robótica mas a inteligência artificial
ela está em toda parte às vezes a gente
nem percebe já tem algum tempo que ela
consegue entender seus gostos e
recomendar produtos filmes e também
facilitar sua vida com tradução de
textos por exemplo mas a gente começou a
perceber a inteligência artificial de
uma forma mais evidente quando a gente
começou a utilizar a ferramenta mais
antiga incrível quem te conhece a
linguagem a linguagem permite que a
gente defina planos traçar ações
permitiu a civilização evoluir até aqui
e e permite que ocupasse conceitos que
estão na minha cabeça para a cabeça de
vocês
e hoje a gente está falando por voz e
texto com a tecnologia
e essa é uma nova interface uma
interface que não reduziu não só reduziu
entendo a flexão uso dos novos aparelhos
mas também expandiu a capacidade dos
mesmos
então eu consigo pedir coisas bem
interessantes para inteligência
artificial como por exemplo pedir pra
traduzir um texto em japonês ou pedir
pra a tocar expandir tendes na minha
televisão ou até mesmo eu consigo pedir
um robot whatsapp a segunda via do
boleto o meu plano de saúde então a
inteligência artificial a tabela não tem
uma forma específica ela é quase
invisível mas a gente começa a ver ela
de uma forma mais evidente
principalmente por exemplo nas caixas de
som inteligentes que são as grandes
apostas
gigantes como google e amazon eles estão
investindo pesado pra fazer com que essa
tecnologia fique cada vez mais acessível
para vocês terem uma idéia um aparelho
de
custa menos de 30 dólares ea expectativa
é que até 2022 metade dos lares nos
estados unidos têm um aparelho desse
tipo
já os sete botes eles ficaram bem
famosos principalmente nos últimos dois
anos depois que o facebook investiu
também pesado em ferramentas para
desenvolvedor e ele estão tendo um papel
instrumental principalmente no suporte
ao consumidor suporte o consumidor que
está cada vez mais digital 93% dos
internautas brasileiros eles já
realizaram pelo menos uma compra digital
na internet e agora esses aparelhos e
esse tipo de ferramenta são um novo
suporte na construção de uma jornada de
consumo agora digital
eu venho aprendendo com esse tipo de
tecnologia e o time da nama já tem quase
sete anos e recentemente nos últimos 20
meses nos últimos 20 meses na verdade a
gente trocou mais de 9 milhões de
atendimentos entre humanos e
inteligência artificial o que dá mais ou
menos 27 anos de conversa mas quando a
gente começou quando estava
desenvolvendo a nossa tecnologia e
validando alguns pontos
a gente assinou um convênio com o
governo do estado de são paulo para
testar uma solução proposta que no caso
é um chat bote pra conseguir auxiliar os
agendamentos e nós tirar dúvidas sobre
os cidadãos a respeito de sua vida com
documentação e tudo mais
encher muitas dúvidas de como que a
população ea reagir com esse tipo de
tecnologia principalmente considerando o
tamanho do estado de são paulo o estado
de 45 milhões de pessoas
mas foi muito gratificante quando a
gente colocou o robô no ar no final de
2016 a gente não fez nenhum tipo de
divulgação mas a gente percebeu que na
primeira semana o bote ele roubou 70 por
cento dos acessos da ferramenta anterior
que existia no site do governo
então foram milhões de mensagens
trocadas mais de 130 milhões de
mensagens trocadas
14 mil usuários e médio utilizando todo
dia da aplicação mas tem um dos números
que eu mais gosto que é o número de
pessoas que falaram obrigado e até mesmo
deus abençoe para a inteligência
artificial
foram mais de 450 mil
deus abençoe literalmente as pessoas
elas estavam bem suas linhas de código
no nosso servidor é interessante que a
máquina lá pode falar com a gente mas
também agora pode falar por nós
recentemente muitos viram o projeto do
google duplex onde ele conecta o mundo
offline com o mundo online utilizando
assistentes que conseguem simular uma
conversa com outra pessoa do outro lado
da linha para realizar agendamento por
exemplo em salão de cabeleireiro
restaurantes que não tem um sistema
próprio um aplicativo para isso e foi
incrível ver a interação entre humano e
máquina nesse nesse caso principalmente
porque não foi só utilizado componentes
de linguagem verbal mas também de
linguagem comportamental como pausas
muros além da magnífica engenharia de
sintetizar a voz humana é interessante
ver que as pessoas elas percebem as
interações que elas têm computadores
como se fossem interações com outros
seres humanos
então existem já muito tempo diversos
estudos sobre como construir uma
interação com a máquina pra ela ser mais
engajam ante para converter mais e tem
alguns elementos que se destacaram por
exemplo a máquina ela tem que obedecer
entender muito bem os seus comandos
mas tem outros componentes como por
exemplo você mulá uma personalidade e
normalmente uma personalidade que é
extrovertida divertida e que tem voz de
menina acaba se destacando na
preferência tanto de homens quanto de
mulheres mas nesse ponto acaba surgindo
um novo desafio que é construir uma
personalidade que é universalmente
agradável mas é como que essa
personalidade agradável ela acaba
reagindo às situações que não são tão
agradáveis assim olsson contextos que
isso é um pouco contou
e foi pensando nisso que a revista 4 ela
fez um estudo bem interessante sobre a
reação dos assistentes pessoais pra
alguns tipos de assédios insultos e
demandas absurdas que muitas vezes as
pessoas fazem por brincadeira mas às
vezes né esse é e acaba se perpetuando
estereótipos que são questionáveis
durante essa interação
nesse caso nem deu pra perceber que a
máquina ela sempre tentava fugir do
assunto ou ter uma resposta positiva
bonitinha diante de uma áudio de algum
tipo de abuso desse tipo
então esse é um novo tipo de situação
que faz a gente pensar com a nossa
responsabilidade como desenvolvedor
desse tipo de tecnologia
um componente integrante da inteligência
artificial hoje é o famoso machine
learning o aprendizado de máquina
basicamente o aprendizado de máquina ele
precisa ser você precisa de uma base
inicial para você conseguir treinar os
algoritmos onde a máquina vai achar
padrões extrapolar para fazer suas
admirações então um componente essencial
para o aprendizado de máquina é o viés
humano sem o viés de quinta alimentando
a base não daria para fazer predições aí
aparece uma outra questão qual a
diversidade dos talentos e como que essa
classificação é representativa da
sociedade
são várias questões novas que estão
surgindo e têm muito receio sobre como
que a inteligência artificial ela vai
atuar de forma positiva ou negativa na
sociedade
muito se fala das máquinas roubando
empregos mas é possível a gente pensar
em como ela a inteligência artificial
consegue ter uma conclusão positiva na
sociedade na questão dos empregos ao
invés de entender a haia como ladrão dos
novos empregos
a gente consegue ver ela como os ou um
potencializador das capacidades das
capacidades dos profissionais
as máquinas trabalhando em conjunto com
pessoas conseguem ser melhores que
pessoas trabalhando só
linhas e que máquinas trabalhando
sozinhos isso aumenta a eficácia em
diversos contextos hoje tem bilhões de
aparelhos e e devices que estão
conversando com a gente de forma natural
entendendo a nossa língua e isso traz
novas implicações e novos e seis também
mas é possível a gente vê um futuro
brilhante quando a gente tem valores
fortes na hora de desenvolver novas
aplicações
a inteligência artificial é uma
ferramenta incrível mas ela é uma
ferramenta que as pessoas têm que vir
primeiro
tanto na hora de construir uma
experiência de uso quanto na hora de
pensar como que essa ferramenta consegue
expandir as nossas capacidades
o estado da arte da inteligência
artificial indica que a gente tem um
caminho de como evoluíram e por com
evolução entende-se por nós ajudando a
máquina a evoluir ea máquina nos
ajudando e evoluir
então nesse cenário onde a gente tem
inteligência artificial por toda parte
as respostas ea percepção da marca das
máquinas vão refletir as da sociedade
somos todos responsáveis para trazer um
amanhã mais simples e leve porque agora
não só as pessoas aprendem com os nossos
atos
mas também as máquinas obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]